[APPLAUSE]
ALLEN HUANG: Hi guys.
Hi everyone.
My name is Allen Huang.
I'm a Product Manager
on the Android TV Team.
And this is John Affaki, one
of the Engineering Managers
on the Google Cast Team.
So today we're
here to talk to you
about developing compelling
applications for the home,
particularly in the living room.
Hopefully you guys are
all in the right place.
So over the past
couple years, Google
has been building out
an ecosystem of devices
to make it just easier for
you to take your existing apps
and extend them to all
living room devices.
So we started with the launch of
Chromecast, the first endpoint
of Google Cast.
So Google Cast has since
extended to the Android TV
platform, a platform we've
built that extends Android
to smart TVs and set-top boxes.
And finally, Google
Cast for audio,
which extends the reach of apps
beyond televisions and just two
speakers.
So then we'll talk a little
bit about the opportunity space
and why you should be paying
attention at all to the living
room.
Hopefully it's not
a huge surprise,
but good to go over that.
We'll then move
on to the anatomy
of Android TV and
Cast applications,
how to build them,
and how we're trying
to make it as easy as
possible for you guys.
And then finally,
we'll talk about making
your app more discoverable
and just ways for you
guys to increase engagement.
All right, so let's-- All
right, so-- sorry about that.
So let's start with
what we're doing
and what our goals are
in the living room.
So we want to enable
sort of rich experiences
on the wide range of home
entertainment devices,
but yet we don't want to be
another attempt at the living
room.
A lot of people have tried
different things here,
and it can be tough.
And we want to make
it easier for you.
So we understand that not
every user is the same.
Their homes, living rooms,
their setups are very different.
And hardware manufacturers
manufacture a lot
of different types of products.
So we think that
it's really important
to give both users and
consumers, OEMs and developers
different options to get
into the living room.
So in order to recycle, we built
out Google Cast and Android TV.
So these are two
complementary ways
to build applications
for your users.
Both take advantage of the
work that you've already done,
particularly on mobile, and on
your existing phone and tablet
apps to bring that to the full
living room device ecosystem.
So for those of you
that don't know,
Chromecast is a
small HDMI dongle.
It enables any television,
whether it's smart or it's not,
to run applications
and to get your content
onto the big screen.
And it does so by extending
your mobile application
so that it's communicating
with the television.
All the interaction happens
on your phone or your tablet
or even your web
browser, and you
can build where you're
building the rich interactive
experiences and you're
not intruding on what's
going to be on screen.
So we've been really happy
with the success of Chromecast.
In fact, it was the number
one selling streaming device
last year, outselling
all other devices
in that category combined.
So we attribute a
lot of that success
to just how simple the
interaction model is.
People are already familiar
with using these apps
on their phones, using
them all the time.
And we take advantage
of that users
are going to be
familiar with that,
and that you just cast
that to the big screen.
So with the launch of
Chromecast our goal
was to introduce that
interaction to the world,
and it's really taken off.
Users are clicking that
Cast button like crazy.
So over one and a half
billion times just
on the Chromecast device itself.
And since launch, the overall
use per device is up 66%.
So given the way
Google works, we
think a lot about ecosystems.
We wanted to open up
that functionality
and extend it to different
device manufacturers
so we could create this
Google Cast ecosystem.
So the other device
ecosystem that we'll
be talking about today
and that Google is driving
and we've been doing for
several years now is Android.
So at Google I/O last year
we launched the Android TV
platform which brings
together Cast, Play,
and traditional television,
and we extend Android
to these new form factors.
So we're extending Android
to several form factors.
We talked about cars and
watches last year as well,
and running that
connection across all
of these different
types of devices.
So by doing this, people
are already familiar
with Android, both
the combination
of how to develop
for the platform,
as well as how you deploy apps.
And so we're just
extending that.
When we talk about
making it easy,
that's really what
we're trying to do.
You're already familiar
with all of those things,
so we just want to extend
that to all the different form
factors.
Since the launch of
the platform last year,
we launched the
Nexus Player device
for Android TV back
in November and that
was really just a start.
We're seeing a lot more
smart TVs and set-top boxes
that are launching this year.
So just this month, Sony
launched their 2015 line
of Bravia television, so you
can find in store now running
Android TV.
And then NVIDIA and
Razer have launched
their new entertainment devices.
We've also seen pay
TV operator, so these
are the boxes that deliver
paid TV content into homes.
Several of them are
launching around the world,
and there's more coming.
On the app side, we're seeing
a lot of new apps coming
to the platform.
Both traditional names from more
traditional TV like CBS, FOX
and HBO, as well as
streaming content
from like Vimeo and EPIX.
So all of these partners,
both across apps and hardware,
they share this vision that we
have of better living room user
experience.
I think all of us have
suffered through just
lots of remote controls
or difficult TV UI,
and we want to do better.
And not only that, we want to
take the existing experience
of traditional television
and merge that seamlessly
with the open apps
and games ecosystem.
So beyond native apps and
games, every Android TV
also supports Cast.
Which means that all the apps
that you guys have already
built for Chromecast, they'll
just work on Android TV.
You'll be able to Cast to them
without any additional work.
So we love watching
TV and playing games
on the big screen,
but home entertainment
goes beyond displays.
So earlier this year
at CS, we announced
the Google Cast for
audio program, which
extends that Cast ecosystem
that we've talked about,
to speakers and sound bars.
And again, there's
just no modifications
needed to take your app and
bring it to these new devices.
So Sony and LG were the first
to launch their speakers,
but as with Android
TV devices we
have many more announced
and many more coming.
We have over 17 million
Chromecast devices out there
and expect to have
tens of millions
of Cast-enabled
devices and Android TVs
by the end of this year.
So with Android TV
and Google Cast,
there really isn't
a room in the house
that you as developers
can't reach.
All right, so why
should you care?
We have these solutions
that we just talked about,
but what problem are
we trying to solve?
So first off on stats, there
are 200 million new televisions
sold every year worldwide.
And not only that, there
are a lot of televisions
already out there, somewhere
around two billion of them
by our estimates.
The majority of them don't
have internet connectivity,
which means they
don't have any ability
to do much beyond
receiving a signal
and putting it back on screen.
People use them a ton, though.
In the US they're
on for an average
of about five hours a day.
And they're, right
now, using them for,
well, call traditional
TV, watching whether it's
through a paid TV box or over
there through the antenna,
or they're playing
games on their consoles.
Beyond this
traditional television,
though, streaming video has
been growing like gangbusters.
And what we found is that
rather than cannibalizing
that traditional
television watch time,
people are just
watching more content.
They have so many
choices now, they're
just watching more
and more stuff,
being entertained in new
and more delightful ways.
And they're mixing both
of these two things.
For many families, sitting down
around the big screen to watch,
whether it's sporting
events-- go Warriors
if there's any Warrior
fans out there-- not
very many I guess--
their favorite sitcoms
or torturing themselves watching
the Kardashians-- that guy--
is a very social event.
YouTube, Netflix
and Hulu are also
products that just have
become household names
in the streaming space, and this
started on desktop and mobile.
But it only makes
sense that they're also
going to be on the TV screen.
So if you have an application
that delivers content
there's great
opportunity for you here,
and hopefully that's
why you're all here.
So here's some
data that we found
to illustrate that opportunity.
So we see a 45% increase in
overall watch time on YouTube
across all devices for users who
start casting to a Chromecast.
So that's a little
bit of a mouthful.
So what we're finding is
that overall YouTube usage
across whatever form
factors, once someone
has gotten a Chromecast
usage starts increasing.
And there's three reasons
that we've attributed to that.
So first is when you share the
experience of a music video,
it's so much easier
on a television
than when you're all going
to be crowded around a phone.
The second is that
if you're going
to watch extended
amounts of anything
it's just like easier if
you're going to do around a TV
rather than on a mobile device.
And the third is that
watching it on a TV
enables scenarios like
party queues for example,
where everyone can
sort of queue up
different content
for the screen.
And these things just aren't
possible on a mobile device.
The other thing that we
found is that the bigger
the screen size the more
time people spend on them.
And this applies to both
Cast and Android TV.
At the rate cell phones
are growing, however,
so next year's 75" Nexus
phone might be the most
engaging screen in your house.
You didn't hear that here.
And that was also a joke.
[LAUGHTER]
Please don't tweet that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALLEN HUANG: 100" Nexus phone.
Starting with your existing
Android or iOS application
and leveraging a
big screen, you're
going to increase
engagement, which will just
increase the overall
opportunities and revenue
opportunities that you have.
So given that streaming
and digital downloads
is how most people are
enjoying their music today,
it's surprising we
haven't seen that much
of an evolution in how people
are listening to music.
So in the US,
people are listening
to an average of about four
hours per day of audio.
So that's quite a lot
combined with that TV figure.
So headphones are
great when you're
listening to music on a bus.
But in the home it
doesn't really make sense.
You want to be
more unencumbered.
And so Bluetooth and
Bluetooth speakers
have started to bridge
that gap and you're
starting to see
some change in that,
but they're still pretty
significant drawbacks there.
Besides the lower audio
quality that you get from it,
it relies on the smarts
being all on your phone
or on your mobile device.
It has to be on, it
has to be within range.
So with Google Cast for
audio, all of that processing
happens on the Cast device.
So you can throw your
phone out the window.
Please don't actually do that.
And any other device can now
pick up and control that music.
So you can create really
interesting applications
here like virtual
DJs where everyone
puts their favorite songs
on, or build features
that take advantage of the
mobile device and drive
revenue, such as interactive
or contextual ads.
So all of your
favorite music apps
available in Cast just
work on Cast speakers.
So you can take your
Pandora, your Google Play
Music, your iHeartradio
to that next level.
So we talked about building out
that ecosystem and why we think
there's an opportunity here.
But a lot of people
have tried this.
A lot of different
companies have
tried to introduce
custom development models
and enforcing
developers to build
these apps that will really
only work in a single device
ecosystem.
This has led to a
lot of fragmentation,
both in the development
platform, as well
as the payment platforms.
And the challenge that we
see is that it's really
stifling to innovation.
We see it like smartphones
before Android and iOS.
What's happening is that
instead of really focusing
on building amazing
experiences, you're
more worried about oh, shoot.
How am I going to
get this service
on these types of devices
and this type of device
and 20 other platforms
that are out there.
And not only that, a lot
of these new platforms,
you have to start from scratch.
It's something
completely unfamiliar
for a lot of developers.
So our goal with our open
ecosystem for the living room
is really trying to bring
some sanity and scale to that.
Just leverage existing
platforms, again,
like Android, iOS, web.
And the development practices
you already know and love.
So our hope is that you can
take that existing mobile app
and just expand them
to the living room.
To tell you a little bit
more about what that means,
John is going to talk
about building apps
for Google Cast and Android TV.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN AFFAKI: Thanks.
So we've talked a lot
about the devices,
so let's talk a
little bit about what
it takes to build those apps.
So our goal, as Allen said, is
to make it as easy as possible
for you to dive in to building
applications for the living
room.
So we're going to start by
talking about Android TV
first because that's pretty much
straightforward for any of you
guys who have already
built Android apps.
The reason it's straightforward
is because Android TV
is just Android.
It's the same APIs,
same development model,
and same distribution model.
The biggest difference
with these apps
is how your users
interact with them
and how they watch the content.
So that means that you need
to do some small tweaks
to your application to deal with
maybe a different form factor.
So instead of being touchscreens
like most Android devices,
the users interact with Android
TVs using either remote control
or a game controller,
and that has a four-way D
pad with center click, a
back button, a home button.
You can also use voice to
drive data entry or use voice
commands like "play Beyonce."
So because of that
interaction model,
building a UI for remote control
is a little bit different.
Instead of a user being able
to touch pretty much anywhere
on the screen, you have
to be able to support
scrolling or tabbing through
the controls on the screen.
So if you've built apps, your
Android apps with accessibility
in mind or keyboard support,
you're already kind of there.
But if you haven't, please do.
Accessibility's important.
So another big difference
in these applications
is that your users are
essentially leaning back
and sitting 10 feet away.
We talk about the 10 feet UI.
And so even though the
big screen is-- well,
the screen is much
bigger than on a phone--
you're really
going to be tempted
to cram a lot of information on
that screen, but don't, really.
Your users do not want to read
walls of text on television.
They really want to
see cinematic action,
smooth transitions,
and the reality
is they have a beautiful TV that
they spent a lot of money on
and they want to see
their content all the time
uninterrupted.
It's not a phone.
It's not a computer.
So any kind of
complex interaction
is going to turn them
off and frustrate them.
So as a developer, you're
going to build your apps
and you're going to deploy
them like pretty much
any other application that you
do through the Play Developer
Console.
But in this case,
you're going to opt in
to having them deploy
it to the television.
So in order to make sure
that the users don't end up
with a really
frustrating experience,
we do manually review that
every application works
well on televisions, instead of
being like a touchscreen app,
but you try to make
it run on the TV.
So in order to help you
deal with those differences
we've actually
introduced a library
that we called Leanback
Support Library.
It brings you some
great fragments
to help you deal with the
navigation experiences
that most of the
media applications
that you would build
for televisions use.
And they support
all the animations,
the navigation,
the D pad support
without you needing
to do any work.
Here's an example of
one of the fragments.
This is the DailyMotion app
that uses a browse fragment,
and it showcases videos in
smooth scrolling categories.
And in this fragment
on the far left,
you can actually
also optionally use
the fast lane, which
will provide you
an overview of all the
categories that are available.
Now, after browsing
from the browse fragment
it's pretty natural
to click on something
and go into the
details fragment.
So here's an example of
the details fragments
in the Plex app for one of my
favorite TV shows, "Big Bang
Theory."
And what that allows
you to do is essentially
pick actions that are
associated with that detail.
Again, all of that's done
by the detail fragment.
Now, with Android M we're
introducing a new version
of the detail fragment-- and
we saw the detailed fragment
in the previous slide.
This is a full
bleed version of it.
Now, both this one
and the existing one
are customizable to show
whatever kind of content-- so
custom actions-- related to the
content that you want to see.
So for example,
if you want to put
more of this particular
version of the fragment
highlights actions such as buy,
rent, and add to wish list,
rather than the
metadata which is highly
visible in the previous one.
So you'd use this one if you
wanted to focus more on that.
Now, also when you're browsing
another common destination
is going to be playback.
So here's an example of
the playback fragment
in the YouTube app, which
provides two primary actions
here, rewind,
play, fast forward.
But you can pretty much
customize the actions based off
of what your
application supports.
And then you can also
see secondary action,
such as below on the
suggestion section
where you could
provide more rows
to provide more
related information,
or as we have here,
suggestions for content.
Now, browsing is
likely going to be
what users are
doing when they're
leaning back and
deciding what to watch,
clicking through mindlessly.
But sometimes users use
search, and actually it's
fairly common.
And for that case we actually
provide the search fragment,
and that has built-in voice
support, as you can see here.
We've got a little microphone
icon at the top left.
And this is another
example from DailyMotion
which shows up when a user has
actually clicked on Search,
and we have full support
for instant search
results as the user's typing.
And this actually uses
exactly the search,
the same APIs that you would
implement for search and data
APIs that you would use
for your Android app
on your phone or tablet.
So finally, with
the latest release
of the support
library in April, we
introduce the guided
step fragments.
And with Android M we
have an updated version.
And this updated version
essentially-- this fragment
allows you to walk through
multistep flows, like set up
or sign up, and you now have the
option to show previous steps.
So if you see here we've
got the multiple steps
getting to picture mode.
And you can reverse,
or you could
choose to show only I guess the
latest step, the current step.
Now, this allows you to also
overlay it over content.
Remember I said users, as
they're watching content,
they don't want it interrupted.
This allows you to
deal with overlays
and you can tweak
settings in real time
with the user being able to
keep watching their Kardashians.
So as we talked about
also, a huge part
of the Android ecosystem is
gaming, in addition to media.
And with powerful Android
TV entertainment devices
by NVIDIA and
Razer, we're seeing
all sorts of really amazing
games being built. Some of them
you can see in the
sandbox area today.
But like phones, the
Android TV device ecosystem
has a variety of hardware that
supports many flavors of games.
Now, we see that addictive
and casual games are really
exploding the size and
diversity of the gamer audience.
And many of the best
games there on TV
span all possible
Android TV devices.
Now, again, because
this is Android
and you have access
to Google Play Games,
you have access to the
full array of features
that that brings you
and that you also have
when developing
games for mobile.
So just being able to
track player achievements,
save games, and resume
on another device,
browse player profiles.
But you can also build
multiplayer games
using the nearby
connections API,
and that allows you to find
nearby phones and other Android
devices that are nearby
or on the same network.
Now, this allows you to deal
with both phone-to-phone
multiplayer, but
also use your phone
and communicate with
the Android TV device
to act as a controller.
So while it might be easy to
think that Android TV equals
TV shows, movies
and games, you'd
really been missing
out on the opportunity
to build some really great
interactive experiences.
As example, I love
to cook, and you
can see it's not particularly
practical to cook it
with the tablet.
So I'm parti--
well, that's not me.
Just FYI.
So I'm really excited to
see interactive cooking
apps that'll walk me
through complex recipe.
Now, I know Allen's crazy about
karaoke, but I heard him sing,
so please, no karaoke apps.
So you can learn more about
developing for Android TV
by checking out the DevBytes or
getting posted online and going
to developers.android.com/tv.
Now, remember that
you can also develop
for Android TV the
same way that you
would for a Chromecast or
any other Google Cast device.
So let's talk a little bit about
the Cast development model.
Now, when we looked at
the living room for Cast,
it was very important
for us to look
at what the typical
household's like or wants.
It would be very easy for
us to stand some ground
and limit our reach
to Android devices.
But we really wanted to
build an ecosystem that
supported choice, particularly
non-homogeneous households.
And we know that many of
you guys use 3D devices,
so it was important for us to
support both Android and iOS.
And for those of you guys who
are using laptops or desktops
to interact with your TV,
we have full integration
with Chrome.
Now, if there are any
iOS developers out
there who are watching who
are worried about the fact
that iOS is not a high use
case for us, well, roughly half
of our mobile usage
with Cast is iOS.
So out of the 1.5 billion Casts
you've got 40% of that is iOS.
So there's plenty
of usage on iOS.
So it's a great
opportunity for you
to deal with your
multi-platform apps on Cast.
So now, as Allen
mentioned earlier,
Cast is really about extending
the mobile experience
onto the television or speakers.
So that basically means
that development for Cast
is about multi-endpoint
development.
So you now have two components
to your application.
One that runs on
your Google Cast
device, such as your
Chromecast, your Android
TV or your speakers.
And we'll call that the
receiver application.
And one that runs on
your mobile device, which
is the sender application.
Now, both of those things are
connected by the Google Cast
SDK, which allows your sender
application to discover,
connect to, and communicate
with your receiver application.
So with that, let's start
talking about the receiver
application.
So the receiver application
is a small web application
that runs directly on
the Google Cast device.
And that's what the user sees.
It what's outputs the video
to the TV or the sound
to the speakers.
So for simple media apps,
we provide, actually,
a default player
to which you can
send most video or audio
formats without writing
a single line of code.
But you could also make
simple customizations to it,
such as skinning by just
using CSS and providing us
with a custom CSS.
Now, for richer
applications you could
build your own application
the same way that you
would build a small web
page, which is basically host
your own HTML and JavaScript.
Except that you'd add
the Cast SDK to it.
Once the Cast SDK
is integrated you
can now send and
receive commands
to that web application from
your sender application.
Now, if you're
playing back media
that uses DASH, Smooth Streaming
or HLS, or any kind of DRM
that we support,
the Cast SDK also
provides a rich
media player which
makes playback of that
content on any Cast device
an absolute cinch.
So within that
receiver, you also
have access to the
device's properties,
just like Android
has properties,
Cast devices have properties.
One of those
properties, for example,
is whether or not
there's a display.
Really there's not much point
spending two or three seconds
showing a splash
screen on your speaker.
So you probably want to make
sure that you skip that part.
Now, remember,
essentially, when we
talk about Android TV we
talked about the simplicity
of development and keeping
it simple for the user.
And so you want
to use the screen
the same way that we
talked about which
is keeping it useful
for the things
that it's great at which
is rendering content,
not very much data.
If you want complex
interaction or a lot more data,
that's when your sender
application comes in.
So the sender application is
what your users interact with,
and you're pretty much
quite familiar with them.
It's your typical Android,
iOS or web application,
which you could either
build from scratch,
or if you already
have one that you're
looking to extend to
the TV you can use that.
They're developed
exactly the same way
as you would develop
them if they weren't
Cast enabled, except you include
the Cast SDK to send messages
to your receiver application.
Now, this is great
for your users
because they don't need to learn
a new kind of user interface.
If they know how to use
your app without Cast,
they know how to
use it with Cast.
So once you integrate
the Cast SDK--
you can see an example here with
Play Music and Play Movies--
the Cast icon shows up and once
the user clicks that, it'll
basically provide a
device picker to pick
a Cast device to connect to.
And once that's done,
your receiver application
gets launched on the Cast device
and you can now send commands
back and forth between the two.
Now, we provide
the ability to send
specifically formatted messages,
such as media commands,
with our media namespace.
And those are commands
like play, pause, seek,
volume, stream volume.
We now recently introduced
the game manager APIs
which will allow you to send
custom messages for games.
But we also say, well, we
don't know exactly what you're
building for
everything, so we allow
you to pass back and forth
any kind of generic commands
for any kind of application
that you might think of.
So the thing that you
have to also keep in mind
is that in this case your
mobile device is a lot more
than a simple remote control,
because with the Cast model
you can really enable some cool
experiences that you wouldn't
be able to do with
the traditional D pad
remote control.
A great example of that's
the MLB At Bat application.
It takes advantage
of the big screen
to display beautiful
content, high def-- there.
So I'm a big
baseball fan, and one
of the reasons I love baseball
is because I love stats.
But at the same time,
when I'm watching a game,
I really don't want those
stats on the screen.
I want to see the game.
So in this case,
using the MLB app
it's great because I can
watch the game on the screen,
but then get play by play
analysis on my tablet
while I'm watching the game
without any interruption.
Now, the other thing
that you have to remember
is that in this case your
remote control is a rich device
and it's got a touch screen, a
camera, a speaker, a gyroscope.
And it's also likely
that if you've
got multiple people
in the room with you,
they probably also have
one in their pocket,
so they bring their own
controller in this case.
And we're seeing many
developers leveraging
the features of mobile
devices to build some really
innovative apps and games.
One of the great examples that
you could see today in the area
outside is a game
called Fitflap.
It's a fitness game
that really proves
that pigs can already fly, so
no matter what they tell you.
And the way that it works
is it takes advantage
of the camera on your phone,
the front-facing camera,
and it captures motion
and basically looks
at your movements to detect
when you want your pigs to flap
their wings or various actions.
So you could go and try it out.
Now Fitflap's not the only
game we have for Cast.
In fact, many of our
partners have launched
games over the last few months.
We brought some popular classics
like Wheel of Fortune, Monopoly
Dash, but we also bought a
little bit more high action
and heart-pumping action
with Just Dance Now.
Now, they're just
great examples of games
that you could be building.
And so this week we announced
the Google Cast games manager
API for the SDK, which makes it
a lot easier to introduce Cast
into your games, and it manages
game state, player states,
and communications
with the Cast device.
With that we're showing
a bunch of games
that are using these
APIs in the area upstairs
and you'll be able to
download them from the Play
Store or the App Store soon.
One of those is
Catch Phrase Blitz.
It's kind of interesting to
walk by the section upstairs
and you hear a lot of
yelling and they're all
playing this game.
So it's a very passionate game.
Also with these
games, you can also
remember that with,
just like Android TV,
you're building your games
mostly on the mobile device,
so you have access
to all the features
that play games provides you.
So everything that you could
do building a game mobile,
you can also extend here.
So really building
rich multiplayer games
is absolutely easy on
either Android TV or Cast.
And so also with
the technologies
that I just
described, you can see
that we're really trying
to leverage your existing
expertise of well-established
platforms with either Android,
iOS, or web development
for the senders.
And then we have a
small extra thing
which is the HTML
app for the receiver.
So there isn't much
new to learn here.
But with all that,
there's still some times
when you want to stick
to native development,
even for the things that are
running on the Cast device.
So we launched the
remote display APIs
for both Android and iOS.
And so with that you
can now actually build
all of your UI natively,
draw to a hidden canvas,
and have that rendered directly
on the Google Cast device,
which allows you to provide
some rich, fast-paced action
on the TV, taking advantage
of the really powerful CPU
and GPU that you
have in your pocket.
Now, a great example of
that is Autodesk Pixlr,
which gives you the
ability to do real time
editing of your
photos on your phone
and renders the
output on the TV.
And that way either
everybody in the room or you
could see the beautiful
photo and what
the outcome of
that edit would be
without being obstructed
by the controls
that you'd see on your phone.
So Pixlr is a great app.
But the remote
display feature's also
particularly relevant to gaming,
where many of your assets
might be shared between what
you'd show on your phone
and what you'd
show on the screen.
And we've had Android
mirroring for a while,
and that was good, but
fairly limited for gaming.
But it was important for
us to give iOS developers
access to the processing
power of those phones.
Whether you're using-- you can
use Medal, you can use OpenGL,
or you can even take UI
Kit and specify a surface
and provide your
audio to the Cast SDK.
And the Cast SDK
will essentially
encode stream and render
whatever that surface was
on the Cast device,
and you can really
enable some great experiences.
Now, Fitflap that I
talked about a bit
was developed using
a remote display.
But you can also check out
a few other great examples,
such as Ubisoft's Driver
or Rolocule's Motion Tennis
on Android and
iOS, and you'll be
able to find them if you're
not at the sandbox area
on your mobile
stores pretty soon.
So you can get a lot more
information about developing
for gaming with Google, and
many of the online videos
that'll be posted
with the I/O batch.
And you could find out a
lot more about development
for applications for
Chromecast, Cast for Audio,
as well as Android
TV in our Dev Bytes
at developers.google.com/cast.
So Allen?
ALLEN HUANG: Cool.
[APPLAUSE]
So now that you've
built your app,
how do you help people find it?
To be frank, your beautiful,
amazing, fluid, teleportation
app, it's pretty useless if
no one actually ever finds it.
So for Google Cast,
since the interaction
with the users on
the mobile device,
the way people find the
app is pretty familiar.
It's how people are finding your
app on mobile phones already.
Millions of users a month
go to g.co/castapps.
It's a mouthful.
g.co/castapps, which will list
out all the Cast applications
and filterable by the
different mobile platforms.
You can also filter
based on whether or not
it's something optimized
for an audio device.
On Android you can
find your Cast apps
in the Google Play Store
in the Cast section
there in the Category View.
And on iOS you'll find
the apps in the App Store.
We've got some
fun, exciting stuff
to enhance Cast app discovery
coming up later this year,
so stay tuned.
App discovery on Android
TV is similar to how
you're thinking about it
on other Android devices.
What you're doing
is you're still
distributing to
over 100 countries
through the Play
Developer Console
and uploading your app there.
So your app is then available
on Android TV devices
and found in the Play
Store on television.
We're rolling out a
big update to our TV
Play Store in this
coming week-- next week--
to better expose the hundreds of
apps and games on TV to users.
Introduce browsing via a
wide set of categories,
as well as sort of
top apps and games.
Once users have found
your app, you'll
want them to engage
and use your app.
So obviously, the content
that your app provides
is the number one most important
thing, but there's more to it
than that.
So Android TV provides
a couple surfaces
for you to expose your
great content, helping
users get entertained.
And so when users
are at home they're
sitting down on their couch.
They don't really want to
think too hard about this.
So that's why we've
made the recommendation
or the first thing you
see on the home screen.
Just a couple days ago I saw
the new Taylor Swift video
that everyone's talking
about as the first slot
in the first slide.
And so we've introduced new
recommendation guidelines
that we'll be publishing
to our developer site.
And with M, we'll
have several APIs
so that you can classify your
recommendations better, as well
as helper modules for you guys
to refresh your recommendations
and just make them more
engaging for users.
The two most important
things are just
how often people
are using your app,
as well as how often people are
clicking your recommendations.
And those are the things that
determine the ranking order
of the recommendation row.
So another surface
on TVs that we
haven't talked that much about
yet is just the traditional TV
and channels and experience.
This is where people today are
spending four to five hours
a day channel surfing.
There's something
really powerful.
You sit down at home,
you flip on the TV,
you're in the middle
of an episode of a show
or middle of a movie, and
people will still sit down
and just keep watching.
And like we mentioned
before, Android TV's
really about bringing together
that traditional television
and that streaming
content seamlessly
without having to wait a while
to switch inputs, et cetera.
So at home when I'm
watching the NBA playoffs,
I'll often Cast YouTube
clips of great plays
during the commercials.
And what if there were
a channel, though,
that just had 30 second clips
of great plays happening
all the time that I
could just flip to.
So live channels is how we're
going to do that on Android TV.
So what are live channels?
I really think of
it as Cast 24/7.
I'm pretty sure that's
what everyone really
needs and wants.
All right, so can we switch
to the demo or the screen?
All right, cool.
So developers could
publish these channels
to something we call
the TV input framework.
And so it's just a part
of your application
and you publish the
video content and stream,
as was metadata about
what's available there.
And then these get
exposed in the TV
app that's going to be on
all Android TV devices.
So on Nexus players, NVIDIA
device, the Razer device,
what you'll find is the live
channels app that we've built.
And so this is your
standard TV experience.
Oh, it's a little frozen.
And so when there
are new channels that
have been installed, you
can go to New Channels,
I find just some new
channels there available,
and it will start loading
them and adding them
to that program guide.
So there are now 113
channels available.
So when I go back to
the program guide,
you actually find all
of these new channels,
so tons of these music channels
available on that guide.
So the TV framework, it's going
to be available on all Android
TV devices, and these
new channels that
are creating great streaming
content, they will get exposed.
So you can see it on
the Sony TVs upstairs
alongside your antenna feeds.
And you'll also
see, on pay TV boxes
you'll see these alongside
all your paid TV channels.
And now it's just a
channel switch away.
When you're channel
surfing, that experience
is just right there.
Can we switch back to slides?
So we have several
partners that we've
worked with really
closely to publish out
these initial channels
that are going
to be available on
Play Store today,
and we have a lot more coming.
I just showed Pluto TV, there's
also ZouZous by France TV.
So lots of different content
from a lot of different places.
We'll have more coming soon
as we start rolling this out
for more consumers.
All right, back to John.
JOHN AFFAKI: Other one.
ALLEN HUANG: Yup.
JOHN AFFAKI: So
speaking of channels,
in traditional broadcast
TV, after you finish
watching a show the
next one starts,
and the next one,
and the next one.
Once I get started I can
get stuck on HGTV for hours.
And the reason that happens
is because there's really
no friction for me to keep
watching what interests me,
whether it's the next episode
of something or something
that I'm interested in.
So Red Bull TV just
introduced a feature
that we call auto play where
they create a personalized
virtual channel of content to
watch, once you pick one video,
and it keeps going,
and going, and going.
And so we've introduced this
feature on multiple partners
so far, and after introducing
it we see average session length
with those
applications increased
by over 15% for those partners.
So it's something
that you really
want to consider if you've
got a media application.
Now, to help you build that
feature we introduce queuing
and auto play functionality
in the Cast SDK, which
makes it really easy for you
to create playlists, but also
automatically starts buffering
the next piece of media
before the current one
ends, so that the transition
between these items is not
a 30 second buffering time.
It's pretty much instant.
Now, on Android
TV you can already
build similar functionality
using the queuing APIs
and media router.
So basically with
those two features,
building your own TV or audio
channel's never been easier.
Now, with auto play we see
that reducing user friction
increases user engagement.
Another source of
friction is things
that I'll call computery steps.
A good example of
computery step is sign in.
No one wants to sign in
into their television.
Now, we launched
Smart Lock Passwords
with this release of
Google Play Services,
and if you integrate Smart Lock
Passwords into your application
your credentials will carry over
between your mobile version,
or your web version, or
your Android TV version.
And so your user will be able
to save their credentials on one
and not need to sign
in on multiple devices.
Netflix has been our initial
partners, so what happens
here is that when you go into
the Netflix application on TV
once you've signed in
to your mobile device,
you'll see a dialogue that lets
you know that you're signed
into the Netflix account
associated with the same Google
account that you've used
on your mobile devices.
It's that easy.
Now, for Google Cast
your credentials
are probably already
on your mobile device,
so this feature works great when
you've got multiple senders.
For example, if I've got a
Tablet on my coffee table,
I just pick it up, install
the Netflix application.
I don't even need to sign in.
All of my credentials
will already be there
and so it's smooth.
Now, we talk about friction.
We briefly talked about
monetization before.
So we all make great
apps-- hopefully you do.
There's some not so
great ones, but we're
going for the good ones.
You have great content.
But in the end you've
got to pay some bills,
and ideally you'd like
to make some money.
So for your users, if
you think that it's
a pain to enter a credit
card on your phone,
it's crazy on the TV.
But you've got to
understand here
that you've got all of the
goodness of the Google Play
Store, including
your user stored
forms of payment,
purchase histories, APIs
for in app billing,
subscription.
Everything's already there
so you could pretty much
eliminate all of that friction.
Whether it's building
native apps you're
running on Android TV directly
where you have the Play
Store there, or for the apps
for Cast that you're running
on your mobile devices
either on Android or iOS,
the friction of collecting
payments is gone.
Why?
Because we're reusing
existing technology.
So in the screenshot that
we have here, for example,
from Hungry Sharks
Evolution, a big time sink.
I could buy gems to make
my shark more hungry
and I could pay for it using
my wallet or play balance here,
as well as carrier billing that
I might have set up already
on my phone.
So because it's Android TV
or if it's on Android or iOS,
there's really no friction
because we've already set up
the payment system for you.
Now, ads are also
a great way where
you're going to be able to
monetize your application.
In particular, video
ads are something
that TV watchers are
very familiar with
and are expecting.
Now, because these are
familiar on Android iOS
apps, your existing video
ad solutions just work.
If you're already
using the IMA SDK
to deliver video ads regardless
of what video server you're
using, they're just work.
This is one of the biggest
benefits of building
on top of established platform.
So here's a
screenshot of YouTube
where we show TrueView ads
by building as UI on top
of our playback fragment.
So what does this
all mean for you?
So we've talked about the
living room ecosystem,
and it's growing rapidly.
And we believe--
that's why we're
betting on it-- that there's
huge opportunity there.
Now, Google's
providing solutions
for the entire ecosystem
to let developers
like you take advantage of
your existing applications
and websites to easily
get into the living room.
If you've got an
Android application
and your interaction model
benefits a game controller
or remote control, then getting
it up and running on Android TV
is super simple.
And with Razer, NVIDIA and
Sony releasing their devices,
the size of the market
is growing rapidly.
If you're building or already
have an Android iOS for Chrome
applications and want to take
advantage of multiple screens
and speakers in the home, we
have millions of Cast devices
out there, and you could
build some truly engaging
interactive experiences
that could take advantages
of multiple senders at scale.
So whether it's games, audio,
video, or recipe sharing apps,
or whatever you
can imagine, it's
really never been easier to get
compelling apps on television.
So whether you choose
Android TV, Cast, or anything
in our ecosystem, we've
got plenty of support,
and our dev rel team's really
excited to get folks up
and running as
quickly as possible.
You can find more
information about developing
for Android TV and Google
Cast, and you could take a look
at the following links.
And you can also attend some
of our Box Talks during I/O
or watch the DevBytes online for
Android TV and Cast on YouTube.
If you've got any feedback,
please provide it online.
Thanks, everybody,
for attending.
We're out of time.
We could take questions outside.
But thank you.
We really look forward to seeing
what you guys come up with.
[APPLAUSE]